to many people in their youth want both
they want to claim that their parents
are full of [ __ ] or this is wrong but
they don't want to take the jump into
what they claim and so you want both you
want a [ __ ] on the establishment but
you're not willing to take the risk to
prove if you're good enough then you're
full of [ __ ] not bad
you got your prospective
[Applause]
[Music]
if people knew at 20 to eat dick for a
decade like eat it like eat it like live
with your parents or in a studio in the
Bronx of nine like if you knew the
blueprint I was like just eat [ __ ] for a
decade when it's easy most people will
be happy I'm 35
patience is your best friend you'll win
you're young as [ __ ] BuildCraft
you can't imagine how young you are I
couldn't come I couldn't drill it
through your head enough don't put
pressure on yourself which has been in
you know created out by outside forces
whether it's your parents or society or
your homie or your older younger sibling
or who the [ __ ] time is your teammate
when you take time and make it your
teammate instead of your enemy [ __ ] gets
real interesting
[Music]
storytelling super interesting whether
it's serial or whether it's me
interrupting my guests for an hour like
storytelling is interesting the thing
that people don't understand about me is
I'm ghetto
yeah I'm Rocky one two and six you know
that's who I am okay okay that's why I
win man yeah cuz I'm [ __ ] tech like
ask Oh alex is looking right now cuz I'm
[ __ ] yelling at this time my team not
yelling I mean it's super love and he'll
tell you cuz I'm [ __ ] on I'm texting
the team yesterday on Sunday at three
four or five seven nine this morning
it's like eight let's go like cuz I'm in
it so you can't after you make it
then the work starts the making is the
wrong thing to focus on
[Music]
[Music]
hello how are you good to see you I'm
great so I'd love for you to go around
the room and introduce yourself tell me
where you're from and what you've been
working on cool we'll start with that
nobody believes that what they see on
video is who I actually am I mean just
but that doesn't bother me like like
that will eventually be exposed or not
my wiring and then my practicing of my
wiring is just like the inability to
dwell I don't think anybody has control
over me I never worry about my family I
never worry about the government the
president any of it I don't dwell I just
think I'm in control so how do you feel
what how does something feel
insurmountable when you know your income
when you know you're in contrivance a
thought like notice like that was even
interesting to me when you know you're
in control like what are you complaining
about
fix it my biggest thing right now with
youth is do what you want because if
you're appeasing your parents you're
gonna resent them and be regretful your
whole life and then you're not gonna
actually have a relationship with your
parents I look at I spend all my time
looking at old people not young people
old people have played and when old
people hate their old parents because
they did what their parents wanted I'm
like that's wrong [ __ ] it have the
problems now with your parents for 24 36
48 months and then here's the good news
then it's merit if you were right that
you're actually a rapper not a lawyer if
you became a successful rapper
they're gonna be proud as [ __ ] if you
don't well then guess what they were
right at least that you weren't a rapper
maybe you're still not a lawyer but the
merit of the game will play out to many
people in their youth want both they
want to claim that their parents are
full of [ __ ] or this is wrong but they
don't want to take the jump into what
they claim and so you want both you want
to [ __ ] on the establishment but you're
not willing to take the risk
to prove if you're good enough then
you're full of [ __ ] not bad
[Music]
I don't judge myself I feel like I'm
trying I know what my intent is I feel
like I'm trying really hard and like my
big thing is like before you say
something to me like why don't you look
at yourself like it's really hard for me
to get going like you know like man what
I love for all of you to be empowered
with like when your parents say
something to call them out on them doing
the same thing that's what parents do
they impose their thing on you they're
weak your mom is doing what her mom did
to her even though she hated that her
mom did it to her it's how humans work
I'm a big fan of like sleeping in the
bed that you've made I got big ambitions
I'm trying to be out here doing [ __ ]
well guess what nobody should be crying
for me and so I can't complain I'm
[ __ ] put myself out there right I'm
putting myself out there I don't have to
say yes to the interview so I don't have
to [ __ ] be filming my [ __ ] self 24
hours a day
I made this bed I got to sleep in it
everything it comes along with it and if
I do something [ __ ] stupid or wrong
and I get called out on it I need to own
that [ __ ] and I'm ok with that because I
don't think I'm perfect I'm just trying
to stay narrow you think narrow is my
thing you know stay in my lane
[Music]
my job is eating [ __ ] you know like
everything's on me ultimately right I
have tremendous perspective and like I
have no sustained funk like even the
thought of like a day is out of question
like a full day of being in a funk is
just not gonna happen
it just can't like there's just nothing
that can happen that makes me change my
mindset of like how good we have it I
mean if you actually understand anything
about you enough to know this but just
looking around the room the fact that
you're sitting in a building in New York
City in America and have an internship
here you would probably [ __ ] your pants
if you if there was a world ranking on
quality of life happiness like just net
score of where do you rank on earth like
a new system came out it took everything
into account it brain scanned you for
happiness depression all of it what is
your net rank in the world you would be
humbled by how good you're like this I
don't think you have a perspective I
don't think anybody does and I'm not
even sure I do I just try my best to
think about this kind of almost daily
where do you rank out of seven point
seven billion people the answer for a
lot of you is outrageously high
[Music]
[Music]